[موسيقى]
لماذا يتهم السيسي مواطنين فقراء سلميين
خرجوا ليحتج على تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي
بانهم يهدمون الدوله لماذا يواجههم
بالخرطوش والغاز والاعتقالات اليس هو من
يهدم منازلهم تحت ذريعه قانون ازاله
التعديات وقانون
التصالح لماذا ينكر الاعلام الموالي
للنظام خروج تظاهرات بل يفبرك افلاما
ليزعم ان التظاهرات
مفبركه الم تعلن النيابه العامه عن اخلاء
سبيل 8 طفلا من المعتقلين على خلفيه
المشاركه في هذه
التظاهرات الم تعلن المفوضيه المصريه
للحقوق والحريات عن توثيق اعتقال اكثر من
380 شخصا
لماذا يقول الرئيس السيسي ان هناك من
يحاول الاصطياد في الماء
العكر الم تشهد مصر في عهده موجات غلاء لم
تشهدها
بتاريخها الم يجلب السيسي خلال ست سنوات
ديونا تتجاوز ما طلبه من قروض خمسه رؤساء
في مصر خلال 60
عاما لماذا يطلب من المواطنين ان يتحملوا
كلفه خطه الاصلاح اليس مسؤولا عن صرف مئات
مليارات الجنيهات في مشروعات من دون جدوه
اقتصاديه وفي قصور رئاسيه وتفري لقناه
السويس من دون عائد وفي عاصمه اداريه
جديده غير
ملحه في المقابل الا يعمل السيسي شخصيا
على مشروع التامين الصحي
للجميع الم يوجه وزير التعليم لتنميه هذا
القطاع الا يتطلب تحديث اي دوله بناء
الجسور والمشروعات الكبيره والا ياتي ذلك
بكلفه على الشعب ان يضحي ويتحملها وفقا
لشروط صندوق النقد الدولي الم يتعهد بدفع
تعويضات الم تطلق السلطات مبادره حياه
كريمه وبرنامج تكافل وكرامه لمساعده
الاسر اسئله اطرحها على الدكتور سيف الدين
عبد الفتاح استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه القاهره من اسطنبول وعلى الدكتور
توفيق حميد كبير الباحثين في معهد بوتومات
للدراسات من واشنطن نبدا النقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه من
الاتجاه المعاكس اقدمها انا غاد عويس
بانتظار ان يعود الدكتور فيصل من اجازته
ستكون هذه الحلقه الاخيره عندما يعود
الدكتور فيصل ستكون له حلقات معكم باذن
الله ارحب من جديد بضيفي الكريمين سيد
توفيق حميد احد الاصدقاء المصريين ردا على
سؤالي له ما الذي يحصل في مصر يقول لسان
وحال هؤلاء الذين خرجوا يقول شيد قصورك
واهدم
منازلنا ما قولك بهذه
العباره اعتقد هي عباره بعيده
عن الحقيقه اقدر اقول يعني هي ممكن تكون
في ظاهرها البعض ينبهر فيها ولكن هي بعيده
جدا عن لما تتعمق في حقيقه ما يحدث في اي
دوله في العالم فيش دوله في العالم
الرئاسه بتبقى ممثله بصوره مهينه كل ما
رئاسه
الدوله انجليزيه فده شيء طبيعي في اي دوله
ودي ل تاثير حتى على ثقه الناس في هذه
الدوله فلا يوجد اي مشكله ان قيادات
الدوله لازم يبقى في حاجات مناسبه تناسب
مستوى اللقاءات اللي بيعملوها ولكن حته ان
هو بيهدم منازل الكلام ده مش دقيق على
الاطلاق لان البعض للاسف الشديد عاوز يعيش
زي اوروبا وامريكا وبيها جر لها لما يبدي
له فرصه وبيحلم ان يبقى مصر على هذا
المستوى وفي نفس الوقت لا ياخذ بنفس
الاسباب خلت دول اوروبا وخلتهم امريكا
ومنها احترام القانون ومنها اني لما ابني
بيت في مكان مخالف لازم اعمل تعويض ومنها
ان انا ما استغل ارض الدوله لانها ارض
الشعب الثاني وملك الناس الثانيه فاذا كان
في قله ها استغلت القانون وعملت اخطاء
فاعتقد ان هو لازم الناس تعرف ان ده الوضع
الطبيعي في في الغرب كله ان انت لما لما
بتبني على ارض مش مكع وتدفعي تعويض فاعتقد
ان ان ده في اجحاف شديد جدا هذه العباره
انه بيبني قصور ويهدم منازل اذا كان في
منازل هي وضعها قايل للسقوط وممكن تقع
نتيجه انها مبنيه غلط فيبقى كده رحبه
بالناس هو بدل ما تتساب تقع عليهم ان
الموضوع ينظم وياخذوا بيوت اخرى كتعويض او
لفتره انتقاليه حتى يتم تعويضهم تعويض
مناسب عن هي اذا هدفها ازاله التعديات كما
تقول ولكن اذا كانت زاله التعديات هي
الهدف لماذا اذا قانون التصالح او نظام
التصالح يسمح بانك اذا دفعت تعويضا تبقي
على منزلك اذا كان متعديا فهذا يصبح جبايه
وليس تنميه اقتصاديه وازاله
تعديات لانك اولا اخدتي حق غيرك يعني لما
واحد بيبني في ارض مش ملكه فده مش بياخد
حقه لوحده ده بياخد حق الشعب كله اللي هو
كان من حقه الارض دي دي تتباع والمبالغ دي
تروح كما ذكرت حضرتك في المقدمه لدعم
حاجات كثيره منها علاج فيروس هيباتايتس
فيروسي منها الامور الاجتماعيه اللي بتتم
منها دعم الفقراء باكثر من صوره برض فكل
ده ان انا ابني على ارض ملك الشعب كله
واخذها لنفسي استات بها دي نوع من
الانانيه ف ان ان الدوله تاخذ شيء من
الضرائب هو الدول بتعيش كده عشان تعطيها
لمن يستحق هو ده المنطق اما بالنسبه لان
هي كيف يسمح لها لان اذا كانت هي غير
قايله للسقوط فساعتها يبقى التعويض منطقي
اما ان كانت قايله للسقوط فاعتقد ان هم
بيزلو لانها قايله للسقوط او لاسباب مثلها
هذا يستدعي اطلاق الخرطوش والغاز على من
يعترض والله اللي بيعترض بصوره سلميه
حضرتك ما شفناش يعني انا انا لا يمكن انسى
ها
ان من يدعو للمظاهرات مثل محمد علي على
سبيل المثال المره السابقه لما فشل هو فشل
في كل مره المره مش الاسبق ها شكر الجيش
وقوات الامن انها ما نزلتش الشارع يعني
اصلا رد فعل الشارع لما بيبقى سلمي مافيش
حد بيقف ضده ولكن اذا كان بيدخل ناس
بيتسبب في عن او هيتسبب في عن في اي دوله
حتى في فرنسا شوفي حضرتك السترات الصفراء
شوفي هنا في امريكا لما بيحصل وناس تخرج
عن القانون هو ده اللي انا متعجب له ان
الناس بتتعجن ان لما حد ينفذ القانون
عليها يعني ما فيش دوله بتسمح بان حد
يستخدم عنف وشغب ويعطل الشوارع على سبيل
المثال لان ده بياثر على غيره من
المواطنين فاذا كنا بنظر لها من منظور ان
هو كيف يمنع هؤلاء لننظر لها من منظور اخر
ان هو بيحمي باقي الشعب فمش معقوله عشان
قله قليله ان انا اضيع حقوق الغالبيه
العظمى دكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح هل
يعقل من اجل قله قليله ان اضيع حقوق
البقيه يقول لك سيد حميد
توفيق انا اولا عاوز اعلق على تلك المقوله
هذه المقوله انا باكد له انها ايه قرانيه
بتؤكد على بئر معطله وقصر مشيد نعم البئر
معط لا والقصر هو الذي يشيد وانا باكد له
بس على شيء مهم جدا حينما اراد الناس ان
يحاسبوه على بناء القصور قال لا انا ببني
قصور وهبني كمان وحينما سالوه عن هدم
المباني قال انا هدمت وهدم كمان وحتى كمان
هدمت 30 مسجد وهدم
70 هذه البج في الخطاب
والتحدي الى ان يعود البث مع الدكتور سيف
الدين عبد الفتاح اعود اليك دكتور توفيق
حميد نقطه مهمه اثارها الدكتور سيف الدين
عندما قال عندما سالوه للسيسي عن القصور
قال بالحرف واستمعنا اليه بالصوت والصوره
طب امال ايه انا عامل قصور رئاسيه
وحعمل القصور الرئاسيه اولويه بالنسبه
اليك شخصيا انت
مثلا لا شوفي حضرتك انا زي ما شرحت في
الجزء الاول ان ان اي دوله في الوجود كله
بيبقى يعني مثلا الرئيس الامريكي عشان
يسافر ويتحرك عندنا هنا تكلفه الطياره بس
بتبقى كذا بالسكوريت والحمايه بتاعتها
بتبقى عاليه جدا واحد يقوللك اللهم ياخد
قطر ما ظروف كورونا صح لا الدول على مستوى
القيادات لابد لتوفير وقتها ووضعها في
العالم جمع في انها تستقبل الرؤساء
والملوك في حاجه مناسبه ده شيء ما فيش اي
حد يقدر يعاتب عليه اما كلمه ان انا هبني
اكتر فانا اللي استشفيت منها او فهمته
لحظتها لما سمعتها بامانه انه عنده ثقه في
ان اقتصاد مصر هيتحسن لدرجه ان احنا هنبني
بدل الصر اثنين وثلاثه وهنبني حاجات ثانيه
كتير فكان العرض بالمنظور ان ان
احنا منظور اوبتمست يعني متفائل لمستقبل
افضل ان احنا هنقدر نبني ونبني حتى لو
هنبني اكثر كان ريفلكشن او اشاره الى ان
ان نظرته ان في تحسن هيحصل فده انا ما
رايته حينما قال الرئيس السيسي ان هو
هيبني قصور اكتر ما دي معناها ان ان انه
يشعر ان البلد قادمه على مرحله جيده هو
حصل ظروف كورونا حضرتك ودي خارجه عن اراده
الرئيس السيسي تما تماما لكن ماحدش يقدر
ينكر وكل الهيئات العملاقه اقرت
الاقتصاديه ان اقتصاد المصري كان في مرحله
انتقاليه نعلم انها مؤلمه ولم لم يعني لا
اناقشك في ذلك فهي كالرصاصه كانت في جسد
الشعب المصري فساد
وتدمير لامور كثيره وجاء هذا الرجل عشان
يشيل الرصاصه دي والشعب يتعالج شيل
الرصاصه في لحظتها مؤلم فهي دي اي رصاصه
هناك
431 مليار دولار دداخل مصر منذ ست سنوات
بحسب ما اعلن البنك المركزي المصري يعني
نصف ترليون جنيه لا احد يعرف لا اين صرفت
ولا
كيف لا هو حضرتك مش متابعه ما يحدث في
صوره شبي يوميه واو شهريه على الاقل من
مشروعات عملاقه بتم من تحسين في الشبكات
الكهرباء من تحسين في اداء سمعنا ب 380
مليار جنيه على العاصمه الاداريه الجديده
وهي غير ملحه انت تقول مشروعات كبيره اين
المشروعات الصغيره والمتوسطه التي يمكن ان
يستفيد منها هؤلاء الذين الذين تصفهم بان
بانت انت بانهم قله قليله ولكن هؤلاء يبلغ
الفقر عندهم اكثر من
66% لماذا لا يجري دعم هؤلاء اليس هؤلاء
اولويه العاصمه الاداريه الجديده هي
الاولويه اين جدواها
للان انا اقول لحضرتك بوضوح شديد في حاجه
اسمها الانفاق الحكومي لما بيبقى الاقتصاد
ضعيف الحكومه بتصرف في اشياء كبيره عشان
تحرك المجتمع والشعب كله والاقتصاد كله
يتحرك طيب كيف يحر سيد دكتور دكتور توفيق
حميد الى ان يعود الينا الدكتور سيف الدين
كيف يحرك الاقتصاد كما تذكره
حضرتك عندما يبني السيسي في قاعده محمد
نجيب 27 استراحه مخصصه لكبار القاضه 14
عماره مخصصه للضباط تم تجهيزها باثاث
فندقي 15 عماره مماثله لضباط الصف كيف
يحور يعني كيف يمكن ان يحرك هذا الاقتصاد
المصري تطوير النادي الرئيسي لهذه القاعده
تجهيزه بحمام سباحه
وبصالح دث التقنيات الرياضيه والترفيهيه
هذا يح حرك الاقتصاد المصري للمواطن
الفقير في نقطتين في كلام حضرتك النقطه
الاولى ان هو حضرتك ذكرتي فقط ما بني
للضباط وصف الضباط ولم تذكري ان مقابل هذه
الاعداد القليله من من البناء يعني او
الشقق او المساكن لهم في عشرات الالاف لم
يكن ب الالاف شقق بنيت لمناطق عشوائيه تم
نقل الناس اليها فيعني عشان نبقى حقين
نذكر ايه الاثنين دي نمره واحد نمره اثنين
حضرتك كلمتيني على العاصمه الاداريه وهي
شيء كبير وبتقولي قال لها اولويه انا بقول
لحضرتك حينما تبني عاصمه اداريه ايه اللي
بيحصل
بتحتاجي حد يبيض المكان بتحتاجي حد يبني
بتحتاجي ايادي عامله بتحتاجي موتورات
عربيات كل ده بيحرك الشعب كله والفلوس دي
بتوصل للناس في نهايه الامر هو مش بيبنيها
من عدم هو يوم ما بيبنيها معناها بيحرك
الاقتصاد بتاع الناس كلها حتى حتى الفقير
اللي هو مش فاهم هو مش فاهم انا بستفيد
ايه من الصبه الاداريه بتستفيد ان هي لما
بتتبني ها العامل بيشتغل والعامل ده بيكسب
بيديك فلوس وانت بتدي غيرك وهكذا تكون
دوره راس
المال وبعدين هو الرئيس السيسي عمل
العاصمه الاداريه وبيديها مجاني للاغنيه
ما هي بتتباع وفيها مكسب للدوله زائد انها
بتحرك الايادي العامله واللي كلهم
مستفيدين في موضوع بناء عاصمه جديده ف من
حيث انا بتكلم عن الاقتصاد ان هي بتحرك في
البناء كيف يستفيد اهالي اسيوط يا دكتور
كيف يستهد كيف يستفيد اهالي اسيوط مثلا
حيث يبلغ الفقر 66% كيف يستفيد اهالي
سوهاج حيث يبلغ الفقر
60% كيف يستفيدون من عاصمه اداريه كيف
يستفيدون من تفريعه قناه السويس حتى الان
ليس لها اي عائد هؤلاء منازلهم معرضه
للهدم ماذا تقول لهم انت الان بان العاصمه
الاداريه ستقم ستقم الاحوال الجويه مثلا
لا وهل السيسي لا مع عصا سحريه سيدتي عشان
يغير امورهم بين عشيه وضحاه من ايام مبارك
ومرسي والظروف السيئه اللي كانت فيها
البلد 30 سنه انت منتظره الرجل بعصا سحريه
يغير كل هذا في لحظه انه لا يقول كن فيكون
يعني هو في برض امور بتاخذ مراحل في مراحل
عشوائيات اتحسنت في مراحل ان الغاز بدا
يكتشف وبدا هيبدا يدر على مصر المرحله
الجايه فلوس في مراحل ان تسييل الغاز بدا
وبدا دول زي اسرائيل وغيرها تبعت الغاز
عشان يسيل عندنا في مصر ويتبع في اوروبا
دكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح يقول لك
الدكتور توفيق حميد ليس مع السيسي عصا
سحريه عليكم ان
تصبروا يعني قبل مساله العصا السحريه اريد
ان اعقب على بعض ما قال ا استمرار السيسي
في بناء القصور يعتبر مؤشرا على
تفاؤله هذا هذه
مغالطات يا اخي حينما يبني القصور ويقصر
في خدمات الناس اللي حضرتك بتقول هو لا
يملك عصا سحريه فان في الحقيقه انك تقلب
الامور وانك تحاول ان تزيف الامور وترسم
صوره ورديه لعمل هذه السلطه الطاغيه
الفاجره المستبده التي تقتل الناس وتهدم
البيوت على رؤسهم ثم بعد ذلك تقول انه
بذلك يقدم اصلاحا
اقتصاديا اي اصلاح اقتصادي انا عاوز اقول
لك حاجه انا بتاع علوم سياسيه وهقول لك
انا بقول ان السياسه هي ايه السياسه يا
سيدي معاش الناس فان كنت ترى ان السياسه
هي ان يقوم السيسي
وعصابته بانشاء امور تتعلق بهم
فارجوك انت تزيف معنى السياسه وانت لا
تفهم
السياسه في حقيقه الامر ان ما يحدث انما
يعبر في حقيقه الامر عن رجل ظالم لا يقيم
لفقر الناس ولا لضرورته ولا لحاجتهم ولا
لخدماتهم اي وزن ومن ثم رسم خريطه لاصلاح
الامور واصلاح التعليم واصلاح الصحه
واصلاح كل هذه الامور التي تتعلق
بخدمات بخدمات المواطن ما تكلف كثيرا من
هذه المليارات ولكنه صرفها على حجاره وليس
البشر 431 مليار دولار كم صرف منها على
التعليم والصحه والخدمات والدعم عندك
فكره والله ما اقدرش اقول لحضرتك رقم معين
ولكن اقدر اقول لحضرتك نتيجه ان التعليم
في تطوير حضرتك بنفسك ذكرتيه في الجزء من
المقدمه لما ذكرتي بع النظره الايجابيه
بتنظر ازاي ذكرتي ان في تحسد في التعليم
ذكرت انه قال انه وجه وزير التعليم لتنميه
هذا القطاع هذا ما ذكرته في المقدمه نقلا
عنه يبقى ان نتاكد وسنا هناك فعلا تح في
تحديث
وال المناهج اطورت وبقت اون لاين بقت على
الانترنت وده انقذ كثير من الناس وقت
كورونا فدي برض نظره ما نقدرش ب نغمط
الناس حقوقها هنا طيب لماذا تقول بالاضافه
الى الصحه والتعليم لماذا تقول استاذه
الاحصاء بكليه الاقتصاد والعلوم السياسيه
في جامعه القاهره هبه الليثي ان نسبه
الفقراء في مصر تتز بصفه دائمه حتى انها
بالنسبه
لبرنامجي تكافل
وكرامه هناك
7% من المساعدات لا تصل
الى الفقراء الى المحتاجين اليها و 34% من
مساعدات برنامج كرامه تذهب الى غير
الفقراء ايضا هذا
فساد طبعا في ممكن في نسبه فساد انا لا
انكرها ولكن لكن الشيء الاهم ان هل في
محاربه للفساد ده مما لا شك فيه ان ناس
تحارب فساد بدون ديمقراطيه انت انت في
واشنطن دكتور جميل انك اعترفت بان هناك
فساد يا ترى هذا الفساد مهما كان حجمه هل
يمكن مواجهته هل يمكن محاربته في ظل القمع
في ظل انعدام الحياه السياسيه في ظل
انعدام اي حياه حزبيه في ظل انعدام اي
تنافس على السلطه انت مدرك وانت تعيش في
واشنطن ان محاربه فسد تحتاج الى اجواء
ايجابيه الى اجواء من الديمقراطيه
والتنافس والحياه الحزبيه على الاقل اين
كل ذلك الان في مصر السيسي احنا بنشوف
فعلا محاربه للفساد في ناس في مراكز كبيره
جدا منها مستشارين مثلا واحد احد
المستشارين كان باني عماره كامله بستغل
منصبه تم هدمها فاحنا ح
الفدور اتكلم اسحي بس اعطيني ما المشكله
انك تشير
عليها وقائع مناق لما
تقول هشام جنانه ما الذي حدث له عندما
تفوه ضد
الفساد انت تنقلي لموضوع اخر انتقل لك ليه
دلوقتي ولكن اللي انا بقوله ان الفساد
اللي موجود ده واللي انا اشرت اليه موجود
ارث كبير من من ايام مبارك لابله لايام
مرسي ل من فساد مستمر عبر سنين كان موجود
فاللي بيحصل النهارده ان انت كما ذكرت من
يستطيع في العالم انه يغير فساد بقى له 30
سنه موجود ان يغيره في لحظه ولكن هل هو
يسير في طريق تغيير الفساد وعلاجه نعم
يسير في هذا وفي امثله كثيره على ذلك اما
بالنسبه للمستشار هشام جنينه فده
موضوع خارج مش مجرد قضيه فساد المستشار
هشام جنينه له علاقات كان مع جماعات
سياسيه تريد هدم مصر وهدم الدوله باكملها
فالموضوع ما اقدرش انا ادخله ببساطه وانقش
في ثواني معدوده انها قضيه هم من ادخلوه
يعني انت الان انت انت الان تقول ملف اخر
وا طرحت هذه الاتهامات له
والمشكله انه عندما تطرق الى الفساد جرى
فبركه هذا الملف الذي يقول انه على علاقه
بما ذكرته انت الان يعني انت
تؤيد الذين يقولون ان هشام جنينه دفع ثمن
كلامه عن الفساد بتكرار الاتهامات
التي ساقها له ان بدون اي
شفافيه انا ماعرفش مدى دقه اتهاماته
وصدقها ولكن انا اللي اعرفه ان المستشار
هشام جنينه
كان جزء من منظومه في لحظه تاريخيه في
تاريخ مصر خارجه من ثورتين ولا تتحمل
اهتزازات
كثيره الدول في لحظات احنا شفنا دول بتفقد
حضرتك زي ليبيا واليمن وسوريا دول كامله
بتنهار والعراق في لحظات في لحظات بتنهار
ف هذا هذا بسبب تدخل خارجي يقول لك البعض
ساعود اليك دكتور توفيق حميد ربما لدى
دكتور سيف الدين ملاحظه على مقارنه ما حدث
في مصر في بلدان اخرى سميتها انت الان لكن
قبل ذلك دكتور سيف الدين صوتك تقطع عندما
كنت تتحدث ردا على سؤالي عن ان السيسي لا
يحمل عصا سحريه وذكرت رقم
431 مليار دولار كيف صرفت لو لديك ارقام
تؤكد بانها لم تصرف في المكان المناسب
تفضل ادل بها نعم انا عاوز بس اؤكد على
مساله انه حكايه انه لما يبن الاصو بيبقى
متفائل ده ده سخريه من عقول الناس اما
الامر الذي يتعلق بخريطه الاموال التي
دخلت
للسلطات الحاكمه 41 30 مليار قيمه اموال
تدفقت عليه بالنقد الاجنبي خلال الست
سنوات الماضيه بشهاده طارق عامر محافظ
البنك المركزي بيتكلم على و ترليونات
الجنيهات من الحصيله الضريبيه ومن رسوم
الجبايه واللي انا بسميها مش رسوم جبايه
ده سرقه بالاكراه ومحاوله تقليب جيوب
المواطن
وفي حقيقه الامر ورسوم زياده الاسعار ورفع
الدعم وزياده اسعار المواصلات العامه
والاتصالات وخفض الدعم الحكومي اين ذهبت
كل هذه الترليونات
عشرات عشرات المليارات لو ذهبت لمكافحه
البطاله والفقر والامراض وسوء التغذيه
وقرى الصعيد
المنسيه التي تنادي عليه انه اذلها
وجوع في حقيقه الامر مش انا اللي بقول
معدلات الفقر اللي بتقول معدلات الفقر
بتقول قد ايه في محافظات محروومه من الصرف
الصحي محرومه من المياه النقيه وبقول لك
ايوه تبقى في عصا سحريه
431 مليار انا اظن انها عصا سحريه عصا
سحريه لو انه انفقها على خدمات الناس وعلى
الارتقاء
بحياتهم في تطوير
التعليم لو هو حط 40 مليار جنيه لاقامه 73
ال فصل جديد
بالمدارس ها علشان يحل ازمه
التكدس اوريك الصور اللي بتتعلق بالطلبه
اللي حضرتك بتقول ان هم قعدوا بيدرسوا
اونلاين اوريك وهم قاعدين على الارض ورينا
دوريك وهم مش ورينا نعم اه لا يعني ده هذه
الصور منتشره في كل مكان طب دكتور 500 ال
وحده سكنيه انت انت تستطيع ان تنكر تاثير
كورونا شوفي بقى تاثير كورونا انا عاوز
اقول لحضرتك ان هو اتخذها لجانبين اولا
جانب
لترويع الناس زياده
والمساله كلها انه يعلق شماعه جديده يعلق
عليها اخفاقاته وانه الاخفاقات اللي هو
عمال يتكلم عليها بيقوللك دلوقتي لولا
كورونا ابدا يا اخي هو الناس احست ما قبل
كورونا باي تقدم في
حياتها هل طورت قطاعات الزراعه اللي انت
بتقول انت بتحافظ على الاراضي
الزراعيه هل الاراضي الزراعيه انت تضمن
احتماليه ان تقوم ولا تجف بعد ان وقعت
اتفاق تنازل عن حقوق مصر
المائيه مهما قمت الان بكل هذه الامور
وخنت كل الامور التي تتعلق بالامن المائي
ثم بعد ذلك تقول انك تحافظ على ارض مصر
وفلاحي مصر ده حينما خرج الفلاحين وخرج
اصحاب
الجلابيات طلعت اجهزه اعلامك تتبق عليهم
وتقول ده انتفاضه جلاليب ده دولي ما
ينفعوش في ثوره لا الجلاليب هي اللي بتصور
بتصور وبتقول لك يا
ظالم لا تمارس ذلك واذلال
للخلق اتحسب ايحسب ان لن يقدر عليه احد
شويه اطفال يخرجوا ويقولوا لك مش عاوزينك
وارحل تلوح لهم بكل الامور وتقتل من
الشباب ماذا فعلوا هؤلاء بالله
عليك يقولون فقط من جراء هذا الضغط الشديد
الذي تضغط به عليهم وبتقول لهم استحملوا
بيقولوا
اه بيقولوا
لا بيقولوا ماضش نستحمل تاني احنا ماعدناش
قادرين نربي
عيالنا لما يقولوا كده تقول لهم هبني قصور
كمان طيب ولا تقول لهم طيب هشوف اموركم
سعود اليك دكتور دكتور توفيق حمد هو هل هو
اقام مصانع هل هو اقام مصانع جديده ابدا
لكن اقام عاصمه اداريه جديده صرف عليها كل
شيء ولما بيصرف عليها التاني بيقول لك ما
هو بيجيب مبيضين ويشتغلوا ويجيب مش عارف
ايه ويشتغلوا ما هذا الكلام الفارغ كلام
فارغ اذا دكتور توفيق الناس تاكل حميد
الناس عاوزه تاكل
يقولون اه من الوجع يقولون يقولون لا لهذه
الجبايه فيهدم
بالجيش اهذه طريقه للتعامل مع المواطن
الفقير حضرتك بقى في بعض تعليقات سريعه
لازم نقاط هامه لابد ان توضح اولا ضيفك
الكريم ذكر ان هم اطفال بتنزل طب واهاليهم
ما نزلوش ليه لو الموضوع كده فواضح ان هو
في هنا ناس بتحرك مجموعات من الاطفال
اللي هم ممكن مش مدركين الامر والرساله
اللي ارسلها اهالي هؤلاء الاطفال
والغالبيه العظمى من الشعب انهم رفضوا
النزول او ما نزلوش ولا تقولي لي ان قبض
امنيه لم تكون اقوى من مبارك
والقذافي ومع ذلك الناس نزلت في الشوارع
فاللي انا عايز اقوله هنا ان الاعداد الق
نزل هناك قانون هناك تهديد بالجيش هو نفسه
قال حنزل الجيش وهناك قانون نمنع التظاهر
الا في بموافقه الداخليه فعلى اي اساس
تقول ان ليست هناك قبضه امنيه انا ما
بقولش مافيش لا وجود لا ولكن بقول ما
تقدرش تمنع الشعوب اذا ارادت الشعوب ان
تنزل الشارع فاذا كان نزل القله القليله
وما نزلش الاعداد الكبيره فدي رساله من
الاغلبيه تقول لضيفك ان هو مخطئ في تقييمه
الرساله من الاغلبيه بتقول احنا مش عايزين
ننزل النظر عن العدد دكتور بغض النظر عن
العدد لاننا ل نستطيع ان نعرف من الذي
يريد ان ينزل ومن الذي لا يريد ان ينزل في
خضم القمع وفي خضم تعتيم الاعلامي
والتضليل الاعلامي وفي خضام انه يهدد
بالجيش وبالقوه وبالعنف وهنالك من قتل
وهناك من اعتقل
انت ذكر لك الدكتور سيف الدين عن التهكم
على هؤلاء انت تقول قله و وتتبنى الروايه
الرسميه ولا تن تقد انهم تهكم عليهم وترفض
ان تعترف بمشروعي مطالبهم ما المطلوب اكثر
ان يسكتوا وان يموتوا بصمت
حتى لا هم من حقهم انهم يطالبوا بتحسين
ظروفهم ولكن انا برضو اعتقد من حقي اني
اقول ان الغالبيه العظمى من الشعب شايفين
ان الاسلوب الامثل ليس هو التظاهرات في
وقت يا دوبك السياحه راجعه الدوله ويا
دوبك الدوله خارجه من كورونا لما دول
ينزلوا م راض عشان يدوا صوره للدوله في
الخارج انها مضطربه يقوموا يقللوا السياحه
ويضعفه اقتصاد البلد يبقى الموضوع هنا ما
يتخدش ببساطه شديده اه دول شويه مظاهرات
خاصه ان غالبيه الشعب رفض هذه المظاهرات
ورفض المشاركه فيها فما المنطق انعه قليله
اخد برا وامشيه على الناس كلها ام دكتور
اسمح لي انت كيف عرفت من واشنطن بان الشعب
رفض هذه التظاهرات ذهبت الى 100
واجريت استفتاء باب و لا ابدا لا ابدا
بالمقارنه البسيطه اني زي ما قلت لحضرتك
حينما تتحرك الشعوب ما فيش حاجه بتقدر
تمنعها ده مقارنه شفناها من اليمن لسوريا
لليبيا لمصر اذا كانت قله قليله خرجت وجرى
اعتقال اكثر من جرى اعتقال حوالي 400 شخص
و68 طفلا وامراه وقتل منهم واعتقل وجرح
اذا كانت قله قليله قله قليله وجرى
اعتقالهم
الخرج يا فندم انت بتكلمي على 400 واحد
انت بتكلمي على شعب 100 مليون لما بينزل
فيه ثوره نزل قبل كده 30 مليون ايام مرسي
يعني لو نزل 30 مليون في اي قوه كانت
هتقدر تمنحهم فانا يعني متعجب جدا ان ضيفك
حتى الكريم لا يرى لا يرى ان بناء عاصمه
اداريه انه في اي فائده للناس هو يرى بناء
مص
طب ماه المصانع بتنش عشان ابني العماره
يعني لو انا مارتش عملت مشروع اني هني
عماره
وهبني سك وهبني شق وعمل المصانع مش هتتبني
يعني انا لما بعمل مصنع للاخشاب او مصنع
للاسمنت اوصع بيتبني ليه ابنيه ليه لو
مافيش سوق العاصمه الاداريه دي هي السوق
اللي بيخلي
الاقتصاديين المصانع دكتور دكتور انت قلت
الاولويه للسياحه لمكافحه كورونا هناك
اولويه ليس وقت هؤلاء لكي يعترضوا طيب
لماذا لا يحترم ايضا تحترم السلطات
المصريه اولويات الناس في رغيف الخبز الذي
جرى تخفيض وزنه يعني رفع سعره بطريقه غير
مباشره رفع سعر تذاكر المترو رفع الدعم عن
الس بعض السلع والخدمات هذه اولوياتهم على
الشعب ان يحترم اولويات السيسي لكن السيسي
لن يحترم اولويات الشعب هذا هو
المبدا شوفي حض بالنسبه للدعم الدعم ما
اقدرش اقول انه اتشال اقدر اقول ان تم
ترشيده لان لما بتدعمي انت حاجه ايه اللي
بيحصل الغني بيشتريها بدرجه اكتر يعني انا
غني بشتري عيش اكتر وبالتالي انا بستفيد
اكتر الذكاء يقول ان انا اشيل الدعم
بالتدريج وابدا اوجهه للمحتاج لاكثر الناس
احتياجا مش ان انا ادي الدعم عشان الغني
يعني هديكي مثل حضرتك الدولار كان بيدعم
انا اروح اشتري شيكولاته ط بالبندق من من
امريكا ومن لندن ومن فرنسا و الدوله بتدعم
لي الدولار اللي يتم شراء بالشيكولاته دي
طب ده هل منطق يقول كده ولا ان انا احرر
سع الصرف واخد الفارق المبلغ المتبقي ده
ادعم به المحتاج اعالج به التهاب الكبدي
ابني به شوارع تحرك الدوله وتخليها اكثر
كفاءه في الاستثمار ايهما افضل دكتور سيف
الدين اذا يقول لك حرر سعر الصرف واصبح
بدل ان يشتري شوكولاته
بالبندق يعمل بما يفيد المواطن الفقير ما
قولك والله يا استاذتنا انا شايف انه ا
ضيفك في واشنطن ها واضح جدا جدا يعني انه
لا يعرف كيف يعيش الشعب والله انا بقى من
بتوع الجلا ب واهلي من الريف وبقول لك ان
الاطفال اللي نزلوا نزل معاهم اهاليهم لان
الاطفال نزلوا ليه لانه راوا اهاليهم بتذل
راى امه وهي بتدافع عن المكان اللي بوي
اليه انه الشرطه شدتها وكشفت
عورتها انت ما بتقدم هذا طبعا لانك لا تحس
باحاسيس هؤلاء الناس ليه بقى هقول لك ما
بتحسش ليه لان حضرتك عاوز شعب ملاكي على
مقاس المستبد وعلى مقاس الطاغيه عاوز شعب
السياحي علشان السياحه تيجي لكن الشعب ما
يقولش اه هذه المساله ايه المغالطات دي يا
اخي يا اخي انا بقول لك انه هذا الشعب لا
يجد ما ياكله تقولي ما يتظاهر علشان
السياحه بدات
ترجع الشعب السياحي ده عهده مضى الناس لها
مطالب احنا ما بنشتغل عشان السياح احنا
بنشتغل علشان بلد وعلشان ناس هم ملح الارض
ملح الارض هم اللي بياكلونا يا اخي
فكلهم
كفيهم لكن حضرتك بتتكلم عن شعب اخر يبدو
ان انت حطه عندك ماكت شعب ماكت ها بتتفرج
عليه كما كيفما تهوى وكيفما يهوى طغيت
ومستبد انت عاوز تعرف هو دفع دفع قد ايه
من
431 قيمه اموال تدفقت عليه انا عاوز اؤكد
لك انه دفع هذا لشركات
تجسس على
الفيسبوك و وشراء ولاءات جديده الدك دكتور
من اجهزه الشرطه
والقضاء
والاعلام
والبرلمان مادله وسيطر على وسائل الاعلام
بقت كلها اجهزه مخابراتيه طيب دكتور وشرى
اجهزه وشر اجهزه تجسس واجهزه تعذيب طيب
دكتور لانه الاجهزه اللي عنده مش مكفيه
دكتور دكتور انا بقول لحضرتك حاجه دكتور
الوقت اريد ان استكر من دكتور لو سمحت
ليعدل كلفته قليله دور والظلم كلفته كبيره
الظلم كلفته كبيره لكن ايضا الاتهام يتوجب
تقديم دليل انت تتهم كل تتهمه بكل ذلك ما
ادلتك باستثناء وسائل الاعلام التي واضح
من خلال ما فبركته من تظاهرات انها خاضعه
للاجهزه الامنيه لكن شراء اجهزه تجسس وما
ذكرته وشراء ولاءات ما هي
الادله انا شراء الوقات هقول لحضرتك احنا
عاوزين نقارن قد ايه هو رفع مرتبات الناس
وقد ايه هو رفع مرتبات
وال والبدلات اللي بتتعلق بالشرطه
وبالاعشاب المعاشات حتى المتقاعدين من
الجيش
رشوات طيب انه يقدموا دور توفيق ح دفع قد
ايه لشان الموات اللي بيدفعها للمجتمعات
الخارجيه دكتور توفيق
حميد بالاضافه الى ما طرحه الدكتور سيف
الدين نحن ضعنا بالحقيقه في في مره يقول
انا مش حقدر اديك مش مش عاوز مش حاقدر ليس
لديه المال وفي مره اخرى يقول نعم بنيت
وسابني بعد و انتم فاكرين نفسكم ضعاف دي
مصر طيب كيف دي مصر وقويه ومعها او مش
هقدر هذا ام
هذا دول توقيتين مختلفتين مختلفين تماما
لما قال انا مش هقدر دي كان في البدايه
وكان لسه وضع الدوله غير مستقر على
الاطلاق وضعها الاقتصادي مافيش حد حتى من
من كبار المستثمرين عالميين مستعد يستثمر
فيها وكانت خارجه من ثورتين الراجل ياخد
الدوله او الرئيس السيسي ياخد الدوله في
اتجاه بدات تتحسن بدا قاط العالم ثق
العالم ترجع ليها بدا الاقتصاد يحصل
مؤشرات على ان الكريديت ريتن بتاعنا اللي
هو درجه الهتمان الاقتصادي لينا بالنسبه
بدات تتحسن فبدا يتكلم بنظره تفاؤليه
مبنيه على واقع ان في اتجاه تحسن فدول
وقتين مختلفين تماما لما قال انا مش هقدر
فعلا وقتها كان خارج من الثورتين كل الناس
متخليه عنه قدر يصلح كل ده وبدا يتجه ب
للامام ولحظتها بدا يقول انا هقدر ابني
وهقدر اعمل فاعتقد هما وقتين مختلفين تما
اعذرني لكن وفق بيانات جهاز الاحصاء
المصري معدل الفقر خلال العام المالي 17
18 ارتفع الى
32.5% في حين انه كان
27.8% خلال العام المالي ل 15 16 هذا
يناقض ما
تقوله لا ما يقضو لان عدد سكان مصر يزيد
في السنه اين ونص مليون انا عشت في احد
الدول دوله اسمها نيوزيلاندا كان كل
سكانها 3 مليون فلما انت بتزيدي دوله
كامله كل سنه ده يعني انا لو زودت لك مثلا
لو زودت الواحد مهيته 100 جنيه وهو بيخلف
في كل بيخلف كتير في نهايه الامر ممكن ما
يبانش تاثير ال 100 جنيه انا ناجح انا
زودتها له ولكن هو زياده السكان بدرجه
عاليه جدا واللي ماقدرش الوم الرئيس
السيسي فيها دي موجوده من ايام الرؤساء
السابقين وتم تشييعها من قبل
التيارات الاسلاميه وغيرها بان هم منعين
منع الحمل
وغيره تسببت في زياده مش طبيعيه في اعداد
السكان فاذا كان بيحصل تحسن بيحصل ولكن
زياده السكان عاليه جدا بتاكله فلحد ما
نوصل للمعادله دي واعتقد الاتجاه ممكن
الله اتمنى ذلك اعتقد في مرحله ممكن تلاقي
الدوله بت نفس الوقت في نسبه فقر بتزيد
نتيجه ز عفوا ما افهمه منك بانه يجب منع
المصريين من ان ينجبوا اطفالا وهذا اسهل
بكثير من ايقاف من ايقاف بناء جسور بكلفه
174 مليار جنيه يعني بدل ان نوقف الجسور
نوقف
الولاده انا لم اقل قق تعبيري ان منع
الحمل ده تعبير بيتم بانه نقلل معدلات
الولادات لماذا لا يقلل الجسور يا دكتور
ببساطه تريد ان تقلل الحمل طيب قلل الجسور
اولا ليس
اسهل الجسور انت تتكلمي على الجسور او او
الشوارع ولا القصور قال السيسي في مؤتمر
الشباب ان الجيش نفذ جسورا فقط بقيمه 174
مليار جنيه وان اجمالي حم المشروعات يتخطى
ارب ترليونات
جنيه هذا هو ما قاله السيسي الذي يتهم
بانه اقحم الجيش في مئات بل الاف
المشروعات الضخمه التي كلفت مئات مليارات
الجنيهات بينما لا يعلم احد شيئا عن كيفيه
اداره الاموال التي تم ضخها في هذه
المشروعات والرقابه عليها بل لا احد يجرؤ
على السؤال
تفضل شكرا على سؤالك انا بقول لحضرتك
بامانه شديده جدا ان هي في نظرتين للامور
في ناس شايفه ان لو البلد معاها اي فلوس
تجري تجيب بيها اكل للناس وخلاص وفي
النهايه في النهايه الناس دي هتجوع تاني
وتنهار الدوله وفي ناس بتقول انا لا انا
اروح ابني مشروعات عشان المشروعات دي كل
مشروع فندم اديني فرصه اتكلم كل مشروع
بنائي واحد كل مشروع واحد بيتبني في شيء
في 70 صناعه بتتحرك عليه في 70 نوع عمال
بيشتغل في فلوس بتتحرك والفقير ممكن يعلى
فلابد ان ابدا باني انا اعمل مشروع وبعد
ما يتعمل المشروع ده المصانع والناس
بتشتغل فيه وهو اقتصاد الدول مبني على كده
امال ليه اوباما صرف 2 ترليون عشان يحسن
اقتصاد امريكا ويخرجها من الكساد وليه
ترامب عمل نفس الوضع ايام كورونا دلوقتي
ها 6 ترليون عشان يخرجها من الكسات لان
لما بيبقى في انفاق حكومي الناس بت اشتغل
والدوله كلها بتعيش في الاخر فانا دي اسس
اقتصاد انا بتكلم على اف ب يعني مش بتكلم
على حاجه ط ب سريعا قبل ان انتقل للدكتور
ل يجب ان اعطيه مجاله ايضا لكن وفقا
لدكتور توفيق حميد وفقا ل مشروع موازنه
19/20 تمثل الضرائب بمختلف انواعها نحو
75.5% من اجمالي الايرادات العامه يعني
السيسي ياخذ من جيوب الناس ضرائب ليبني
مشروع تصب لصالح حكمه وجماعته في الحكم
ولا نعرف كيف يتم تتم الامور لان السيسي
نفسه قال ان الجيش مؤسسه مغلقه لا لا نعرف
ليست هناك شفافيه في
الموضوع يعني السؤال ازاي بيخد 75% من
ايرادات الدوله جايه من الضرائب ما هو
الدوله اساسا بتقام على الضرائب عمل خدمات
للناس شوارع مصارف
ا كهرباء بتوصل لهم
الغاز وبتاخد ضرايب ههم الدول هنا امريك
لك دكتور سيف الدين الخدمات هذه هذه
الارياف التي خرجت ليس فيها صرف صحي حتى
فعن اي ضرائب واي جبايه
وعن اي تعويضات ي ينبغي ان يدفع هذا
المواطن وهو ليس لديه خدمات اساسيه كصر
صحي دكتور سيف الدين عب الفتاح تفضل رد
عليه دكتور سيف الدين هو طبعا انا عاوز بس
اقول ما تقاطعني بقى ده انت اكلمت كل
الحلقه افضل دكتور يا اخي استنى طيب افضل
اه مثلا يلاحظ ان الضراب زادت
بقيمه 704 مليار جنيه بين عامي 2014
و209 بنسبه تصل الى
27% دوله جبايه دوله سرقه
بالاكراه ايضا القروض العامه زادت في
2014 ل
مصادرا كل المستقبل حتى بتاع الاجيال
القادمه ده خنق مصر يا اخي ده بعها بصندوق
السيادي وبيعرض مشروعات
وبيعرض اصول بيبيعها دلوقتي علشان يسدد
فايده
الديون عمل ايه بنحو
396 مليار جنيه مصري و بنسبه تصل الى
228 في وده كان له اثار خطيره على
الموازنه العامه والانفاق في الموازنه
العامه وارتفعت مخصصات الديون بشكل كبير
بما يزيد على مخصصات الاجور
والتعليم
والشباب والثقافه والشؤون الدينيه وخد
عندك كمان التعليم كله
كارثه الديون المحليه
والخارجيه بتعكس ازمه في الفجوه
التمويليه المسائل التي تتعلق ومش انا
اللي بقول ده اساتذه من كليه الاقتصاد
الفجوه الاست
الاستثماريه اللي هي بتعتمد على مصادر
تتعلق بالغاز والاشياء دي كلها ودي بتعود
في ارباعها للشركات الاجنبيه وما بتروحش
للمواطن انا بس عاوز اقول لك انه انه في
الخريطه التي تتعلق بمصادره مستقبل مصر
وخنق مصر وقتل اهل مصر انا بس بقول لك انه
خريطه الاموال اللي جات له ما صرفها على
الناس ولا صرفها على اي امور تتعلق بخدمات
الناس وانت عاوز يصرفها زي ما هو عايز انا
عاوز اقول لك المشروعات بتاعته كلها كاذبه
وانا عاوزك ترد على هذا الموضوع موضوع
تفريع قناه السويس اللي دفع فيه 8 مليار
دولار عمل ايه عمل
ايه اختم الحلقه للاسف انتهى وقتنا دكتور
حتى لن
يتسنى ان يجيب عمل ايه عمل ايه دكتور
سريعا دكتور توفيق عمل ايه بتفريع السويس
عمل ايه
لك اجاه لان الوقت
انته الاجابه سريعه ده استثمار بعيد المدى
وليس قر المف الدين هذا استثمار بعيد
المدى رد على جواب على سؤالك دد المدى
استثمار بعيد المدى وهو بيفقد شعب مصر وهو
في الاخر بيقولوا له ده ما جابتش حاجه
فيقول لهم اصل انا كنت برفع الروح
المعنويه برفع روح المعنويه تما ينفع روح
انتهى النقاش انتهى الوقت تخيلي انتهى
الوقت والله هؤلاء كذبه
وزائف ويستخدمون خطابا زائف شكرا لك شكرا
لك دكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح شكرا لك
دكتور توفيق حميد شكرا لكم مشاهدينا تحيه
طيبه وفي الحلقه المقبله يلقاك الدكتور
فيصل ان شاء
[موسيقى]
الله
l